That neurological process includes a
sale as soon as,
okay,
make a reaction at the level of the
signups.
And uh,
and this is serious,
overreaction leads to a
changes in the connection.
The synopsis changes that include both
the,
uh,
I was just say
changes in the receptors are located.
The signups is such that these receptors
respond in a different way and change in
the release of neurotransmitter of the
sign opsis and eventually changes in
the,
uh,
the level of the morphology of the
signups,
uh,
such debt.
There was enough,
Dick response becomes much,
much stronger and even an addition to
that for this memory to last long,
there have to be changes in the,
uh,
at the level of the genes that
the top part of our DNA and,
uh,
that are long lasting so that our
genetic changes with the formation of
new proteins in the cells that uh,
uh,
wouldn't live.
And it's a sign,
it's,
it's changed in the,
over their eyes.
It's plastic changes.
Or like as far as more protein,
a new proteins formed at this.
I have the signups.
You say men wanting pass through similar
processes to save our point first year,
memorize what I'm saying.
Then you consolidate this something that
you can recall it when you need to
remember.
Then you can reconsolidate it's a
process which has several
steps are phases.
I bet that it depends on the particular
moment in which you are trying to recall
that memory on certain processes that
uh,
no longer happen in the brain or they
are blocked,
some chemical reaction occur and they
interfere or did not occur and interfere
with this process of recalling in a
certain moment.
And then,
uh,
then,
two shown some data still remember it.
Maybe because you make an association
something in that moment that the house
too,
like,
you know,
so if you associate something with a
particular older,
I make an example and then the other
camps,
then the memory comes up.
It's just those options.
It's also to remember,
well,
I mean
obviously I bet that smell is much more
important for a dog.
And then few months,
although there are humans or exercise
their sense of this male and afforded a
probably much better than I am now.
I mean,
there is differences between St Louis a
way of learning according to the people
and we're not the same.
Uh,
it's like a door that send people a is
more open one door,
then another sword or so they use it one
particular way more than others.
So there are differences.
But if we accept to the way in which the
memory gets in the chemical process that
once this thing is getting that they're
very,
very similar inside of the brain.
They are very,
very similar for different,
uh,
um,
call input of memory coming from
different ways through different
mechanisms.
And they're very similar in humans and
they're very similar in between the
different animals.